Новини дня «Heute» з Мітрі Зіріним.
Усім доброго вечора!
Про новини спорту зовсім скоро
розповість вам Крістін Отто.
Розпочинається Чемпіонат світу з легкої атлетики.
Доброго вечора!
Важливі новини цієї п'ятниці
протягом наступних 20 хвилин.
Теми випуску:
Суперечки щодо ревакцинації -
міністр охорони здоров'я рекомендує
робити четверте щеплення
також особам віком до 60 років,
проте комісія з вакцинації виступає проти.
Важке партнерство - президент США Байден
відвідує Саудівську Аравію і зустрічається там
із контроверсійним кронпринцом.
Героїчна сага в інакшому трактуванні -
починається Фестиваль Нібелунгів.
Цього разу тон задають жінки.
На відміну від минулого та позаминулого літа,
цього року спостерігається висока
захворюваність на коронавірус.
На даний момент по всій країні
число офіційно підтверджених випадків становить 719,2.
Ситуації у відділеннях реанімації
дають привід для занепокоєння.
З цієї причини, а також з огляду на осінь і зиму,
міністр охорони здоров’я Лаутербах рекомендує
зробити четверте щеплення також особам
віком до 60 років.
Комісія з вакцинації виступає проти.
Про це повідомляє Бріта Шпікерман.
Рекомендація міністра Лаутербаха
не нова і дуже суперечлива -
четверте щеплення також для людей віком до 60 років.
Ті, кому менше 60 років, мають самі вирішувати,
порадившись із сімейним лікарем.
Це питання варто обдумати, особливо тим, хто багато
контактує з іншими і хоче провести безтурботне літо
та краще захистити себе, наприклад,
від затяжного перебігу хвороби.
Відповідальна комісія з вакцинації з цим не згідна.
Немає жодних підстав слідувати
рекомендаціям Лаутербаха щодо щеплення,-
говорить керівник Постійної комісії з вакцинації
(STIKO) Томас Мертенс.
«Я вважаю, що давати лікарські рекомендації за принципом
«чим більше, тим краще» - це погана ідея».
Його комісія рекомендує вчетверте вакцинувати
людей старше 70 років, тих, хто перехворів
і медперсонал, та дотримується цієї думки.
Міністр та Постійна комісія з вакцинації
не можуть дійти згоди.
Більшість виступає проти його рекомендації,
проте є одна порада.
Хочу я зробити четверте щеплення чи ні,
також залежить від того,
наскільки високі мої особисті потреби в безпеці.
Четверта вакцинація безсумнівно
забезпечить додатковий захист.
За даними моніторингу стану інтенсивної терапії,
зайнятість ліжок дещо зросла.
Відповідно до вимог Постійної комісії з вакцинації,
щеплення людей похилого віку - в пріоритеті.
Настійно рекомендується четверта вакцинація,
перш за все для тих, кому за 70
або людям із супутнім захворюванням.
Міністерство охорони здоров'я
обіцяє на вересень забезпечити вакцинами,
спеціально адаптованими під варіанти вірусу.
Проте немає ніяких гарантій,
що визначених строків буде дотримано.
Наприкінці своєї поїздки на Близький Схід
президент США Байден прибув до Саудівської Аравії.
Цей візит вважається делікатним
насамперед тому, що він зустрічається із суперечливим
кронпринцем Мухаммедом ібн Салманом.
Кронпринца підозрюють у замовленні вбивства
саудівського журналіста Хашоґджі
чотири роки тому в саудівському консульстві в Стамбулі,
і тому його уникають західні політики.
З нами на зв'язку Ельмар Тевесен із міста Джидда,
що у Саудівській Аравії.
Які інтереси в Саудівській Аравії
важливіші для президента США,
ніж моральний конфлікт у справі Хашоґджі?
Величезні стратегічні інтереси.
Інакше їх привітання - раніше, до речі,
кулаком, а не рукостисканням -
увійшло б в історію як політична перемога
Мухаммеда ібн Салмана
та як нищівна поразка Джо Байдена.
Тому це щось справді дуже важливе.
Арабо-ізраїльський союз проти Ірану.
Загалом, обіцянка Саудівської Аравії щодо того,
що літаки з Ізраїлю тепер можуть літати сюди,
до Саудівської Аравії, – це лише початок.
Крім того відбувається значне
збільшення видобутку нафти,
щоб пом’якшити тиск на міжнародні енергетичні ринки.
І третє - масштабне нарощування економічного
та технологічного співробітництва
з країнами Перської затоки.
Президент США також намагається протидіяти
постійно зростаючому впливу Китаю у цьому регіоні.
Тому ця тісна співпраця спрямована
на боротьбу з авторитаризмом.
Якщо Байден налаштований серйозно,
то йому доведеться вимагати від Саудівської Аравії
конкретних обіцянок щодо прав людини та громадян.
Якщо він цього не зробить, це буде
поразкою його зовнішньої політики.
Ельмаре Тевесене, дякую за репортаж із Джидди.
Звук був, але зображення не завжди.
Просимо за це вибачення.
Ще до поїздки до Саудівської Аравії
Байден зустрівся з палестинським президентом Аббасом
у Віфлеємі на Західному березі річки Йордан.
Він пообіцяв виділити близько 300 мільйонів доларів
на подальшу фінансову допомогу палестинцям
і тим самим підтвердив свою підтримку
незалежної Палестинської держави.
Проте президент США не бачить
відновлення мирних переговорів з Ізраїлем
найближчим часом.
А зараз про війну в Україні.
Вчорашній напад росіян на Вінницю
викликав бурхливу реакцію.
Федеральний уряд заявив про акт жорстокості
проти мирного населення.
Росія визнала, що розстріляла будівлю у Вінниці
крилатими ракетами,
стверджуючи, що там, нібито,
була точка збору військових.
Україна це заперечує.
В результаті атаки щонайменше 23 людини загинуло,
серед них троє дітей.
Жорстка битва точиться в зоні бойових дій
навколо кожного села та вулиці.
Наш кореспондент Дара Гасанзаде
супроводжував український патруль
поблизу міста Харкова.
Фронт, майже 20 км до Харкова.
Буйволи, що втекли із розбомбленого зоопарку,
зараз оселилися у селі Руська Лозова.
Командир Всеволод відповідальний за цю ділянку фронту.
50-річний чоловік є власником найбільшого
агрохолдингу в Україні.
Він обробляє 75 тис. га землі,
30% якої окуповано Росією.
У нас сильна команда тренерів,
які навчають наших офіцерів,
а також солдатів, які були задіяні на війні
на Донбасі з 2014 року.
Негода означає погану видимість
для російських розвідувальних дронів,
а також менше небезпеки для патрульних.
Їм вдалося повторно захопити й утримати село.
Вони регулярно змінюють свої укриття
і постійно знаходять «російську спадщину».
Це лайно всюди, у кожній хаті.
Російська армія знає, що вони в долині.
Це гра в «кішки-мишки» на виживання -
дрони та артилерія проти знання місцевості
та мобільності.
Люди не хочуть більше жити у минулому.
Вони хочуть мати майбутнє.
А майбутнє означає нормальний, вільний,
демократичний світ.
Вільна Україна, вільна від баласту радянської епохи.
Їхній підрозділ має протистояти тут російському війську,
інакше їхня долина може стати воротами до Харкова.
Країна-сусід України, Республіка Молдова,
приймає в себе значну кількість біженців.
Щоб пом'якшити ці та інші наслідки війни,
міжнародна спільнота хоче виділити
країні 600 млн. євро.
Міністерка закордонних справ Бербок
пообіцяла у Бухаресті
77 млн. євро від Німеччини.
Ці гроші призначені для пом’якшення
високих цін на енергоносії
та для допомоги біженцям.
Чи продовжить Росія постачати газ до Німеччини
після технічного обслуговування «Північного потоку-1»?
А якщо ні, то чи існує ризик виникнення
критичної ситуації з газом?
Занепокоєння серйозні, але в цьому
контексті важливо знати,
наскільки ми залежні від Росії,
наскільки заповнені наші газосховища
і яких стратегій потрібно дотримуватись.
Елізабет Шмідт більше про це.
Він продовжує керувати постачанням газу Німеччині.
З понеділка природний газ не надходить до Німеччини
не лише через «Північний потік-1»,
а й через інші російські трубопроводи також.
У цьому відношенні можна підрахувати,
що вже зараз існує загроза,
що після ремонту природний газ
більше не подаватиметься.
Загроза є,
проте залежність Німеччини від Росії зменшується.
У середині березня газосховища
були заповнені лише на 24%.
Зараз близько 65% - значно більше, ніж рік тому.
Втім, як замінити російські поставки?
Норвегія та Нідерланди досягли своїх
експортних можливостей.
Якщо «Північний потік-1» не постачатиме
газ після ремонту,
тоді вихід лише один -
економити, тобто використовувати
менше природного газу.
На початку року Німеччина отримувала
55% природного газу від Росії.
Згідно з дослідженням, проведеним у Брюсселі,
зараз ми залежні лише на 29%
завдяки закупкам природного газу за дорожчою ціною
з Норвегії чи Нідерландів,
а також тому, що промисловість та домогосподарства
заощадили близько 10% природного газу.
Але ці 29% досі залишаються.
Якщо ми розподілимо цю нестачу
лише серед побутових споживачів Німеччини,
тоді люди замерзнуть.
Але якщо ми його розділимо ширше,
між різними секторами в Німеччині, а також в Європі,
тоді не доведеться відключати електроенергію,
ніхто не замерзне
і економіка продовжить працювати.
Ключовим словом є «розподіл».
В межах ЄС та Німеччини.
Постачання природного газу та економія.
Бути незалежним від Москви можливо,
але це коштуватиме мільярди.
Через зростання цін на енергоносії та високу інфляцію
міністр праці Гайль хоче ще більше
допомогти людям з низьким доходом.
Його метою є значні збільшення у наступному році
стандартних ставок Hartz IV (допомога по безробіттю),-
сказав політик SPD редакційній мережі Німеччини.
Схвалення з боку профспілок,
опозиція - з боку урядового партнера FDP
з посиланням на коаліційну угоду.
Є нові політичні прогнози від ZDF-Politbarometer
із дуже цікавими результатами.
Матіас Форноф з нами у студії.
Привіт, Матіасе! Доброго вечора!
Як громадяни оцінюють заходи влади
в умовах нинішньої кризи?
Уряд зробив багато, щоб полегшити життя громадянам:
знижка на пальне, фіксована ставка ціни
на електроенергію та пільговий квиток за 9 євро.
Але, на думку опитаних громадян, цього недостатньо.
Лише 20% опитаних, задоволені заходами,
які провів уряд.
Але більшість - три чверті - вважають,
що цього просто недостатньо.
Занепокоєння все більше посилюється,
шо відбивається на рейтингу політиків.
Порівняно з опитуванням, що проводили два тижні тому,
рейтинг знизився і червона стрілка вказує на це.
Втрати усіх очевидні.
Хоча найбільших зазнав Міністр фінансів
Німеччини Крістіан Лінднер.
Його розкішне весілля на острові Зюльт
викликало шквал критики.
Країні слід економити,
з огляду на дану ситуацію з газом та зважаючи на те,
що попереду осінньо-зимовий період.
А як щодо підтримки України?
Незважаючи на те, що ціни продовжують зростати,
більшість опитаних вважають, що
потрібно підтримати Україну.
70% «за» підтримку України, 22% - «проти».
Більшість голосів «за» віддали практично усі партії,
за винятком партії AfD.
Короткий прогноз щодо
співвідношення сил між партіями.
Якщо б у неділю відбулися вибори
до парламенту Німеччини,
то партія SPD отримала б 21%,
Союз CSU/CDU - 26% (мінус один порівняно
з початком липня),
партія Зелених - 25%, FDP - 6%,
партія AfD - 11% (плюс один), та партія Лівих - 5%.
Відносно невеликі зміни, як на
такий буремний період.
Дякую, Матіасе.
Детальніший огляд результатів ZDF-Politbarometer
у ефірі «heute journal», незмінно о 22:00.
Або на сайті «zdfheute.de» та в додатку
у будь-який, зручний для Вас, час.
Справа, котра викликала неабиякий резонанс:
колишнього офіцера Бундесверу,
який видавав себе за біженця з Сирії,
звинувачують у плануванні терактів
з правоекстремістських мотивів.
Сьогодні Вищий земельний суд Франкфурта-на-Майні
засудив Франко А. до 5,5 років позбавлення волі.
Про події розповість Ізабель де ла Вега.
Це фінальне засідання напруженого процесу:
Франко А., офіцера Бундесверу, засуджено і
визнано винним у підготовці
тяжкого злочину, що загрожує державі.
Я розцінюю це, як успіх у боротьбі проти
правого екстремізму, расизму
та антисемітизму в Федеративній Республіці Німеччина.
Січень 2017: в аеропорту Відня
прибиральник знаходить пістолет, захований в туалеті.
Коли Франко А. повернувся за пістолетом -
його затримали.
Згодом правоохоронні органи здійснюють
фантастичне відкриття:
відбитки пальців, що були на пістолеті,
збігаються не тільки з заарештованим
солдатом Франко А.,
а також з сирійським біженцем -
Давидом Беняміном.
Солдат, під вигаданим ім'ям, попросив
прихистку у Німеччині.
І отримав його.
Більше року Франко А. вів подвійне життя:
як офіцер піхотного батальйону та як біженець із Сирії.
Після його арешту було збережено
десятки голосових заміток
з правоекстремістським змістом.
У суді він зізнався, що забезпечував себе
зброєю та боєприпасами.
Також були знайдені смертні списки з іменами політиків.
Франко А. не визнав своєї вини,
проте суддям здебільшого вистачило
наданих прокуратурою доказів.
Ланцюг доказів вказує на те,
що Франко А. закуповував зброю,
досліджував місця злочину
та практикувався у навичках зі стрільби.
Його метою було вбивство знаменитостей
та політиків, котрі були доброзичливими до біженців.
Франко А. засуджено до 5,5 років позбавлення волі.
Хоча захист вимагає перегляду справи.
Близько 30 мільйонів пасажирів використовують
пільговий квиток за 9 євро.
Акція завершується наприкінці серпня.
Якщо б це залежало від транспортних компаній,
то квиток зі знижкою на місяць
для автобусів і поїздів мав би лишитися і надалі.
Їхня пропозиція - 69 євро на місяць,
що, як і попередній квиток, включає поїздки
на весь громадський транспорт Німеччини.
У курортних південноєвропейських країнах
в місцевостях з посушливим кліматом
спалахує все більше і більше пожеж.
Постраждало від вогню також
французьке Атлантичне узбережжя,
що на південному заході від провінції Бордо.
Десять тисяч людей було переселено у безпечні місця.
Вітер роздуває полум'я вогню все сильніше
і рухається у напрямку населених пунктів.
Іноді це займає дні: приборкати вогонь
та загасити полум'я.
«Сага про Нібелунгів»: трагічний герой Зігфрід,
зачарований своєю
дружиною Крімгільдою і ненавистю до Брунгільди.
Короткий екскурс у світ класики.
Цю історію можна презентувати
цілком по-іншому:
від сьогодні Фестиваль Нібелунгів у Вормсі.
Двоє суперниць об’єднують зусилля, щоб
протистояти войовничій діяльності чоловіків.
Видовищні декорації:
скрізь вода, дзеркальні відображення, монітори.
Крістофер Гайнце на середньовічному епосі Німеччини
у новій інтерпретації.
Великий басейн, як сцена, що змальовує
річковий пейзаж,
актори, котрі постійно знаходяться, то у воді,
то під водою.
Цього разу все інакше, аніж зазвичай.
Це надзвичайно великий виклик:
цікаво, як відреагує організм,
тому що виснаження неймовірне.
Пам'ятаю, як перші кілька тижнів, я не могла нормально
відкрити свої очі,
настільки сильно вони були набряклі.
Так, це дуже круто, але, справді,
дуже виснажливо і важко.
У центрі уваги - героїні саги, войовничі жінки
Брунгільда і Крімгільда.
Просто почувайтеся як вдома.
Його люблять, знущаються, вбивають.
Правитель Нібелунгів стає маріонеткою,
а жінки об'єдналися заради спільної мети,
замість того, щоб бути суперницями одна проти одної.
Йдеться про дуже сильний феміністичний вплив.
Відверто ставиться запитання:
а чи жінки керують світом по-іншому?
Так, жінки мають інший підхід
до влади, егоїзму, політики.
Вистава дуже начасна.
Ми, дійсно, таки маємо справу з фемінізмом,
з різноманітністю.
І передусім також з війною.
Вотан, батько Брунгільди, уособлює у виставі зло.
З актуальними посиланнями.
Все завжди закінчується війною.
Як не крути і не мудруй -
ти повинен це знати.
Цього року Фестиваль Нібелунгів
видовищний, драматичний і в той же час актуальний.
Таку інтерпретацію «Саги про Нібелунгів»,
можна побачити до 31 липня
перед собором у Вормсі.
А тепер до спортивних новин.
Про жіночу збірну з футболу, Крістін?
Гра у чвертьфіналі уже зовсім близько.
Остання групова гра проти Фінляндії уже завтра ввечері.
Дивіться прямий ефір на «ZDF».
Фелісітас Раух і Лена Обердорф, випадають з гри,
отримавши жовту картку.
Знову у формі та тонусі
тренерка команди Мартіна Фосс-Текленбург.
Вчорашнє тренування провів
помічник тренера.
Немає причин для хвилювання, -
саме так вважає тренерка команди.
Зі мною все добре.
У мене просто була мігрень, як і у багатьох інших людей.
Усе чудово, про мене добре дбають.
Фінляндія поки не набрала жодного очка.
Так і повинно залишатися -
покладає надії національний тренер.
Для нас важливо зберігати цей потік,
підтримувати цю енергію, робити хорошу гру,
використовувати для нас цей позитивний настрій.
Успішний тур повинен продовжуватися,
бажано до закінчення фіналу.
З перемогою для Мадса Педерсена закінчився
13-й етап «Тур де Франс».
Після 190 кілометрів данець
відірвався на фінішній прямій від трійки лідерів,
забезпечивши Данії 3 день успіху.
Без змін, у жовтій майці
його співвітчизник Йонас Вінгегор.
Сімон Гешке завтра теж братиме участь в гірському заїзді.
П'ятий день поспіль, так часто,
як жоден німецький професійний велосипедист до того.
Вперше в США, у місті Юджин, з сьогоднішнього дня
відбувається Чемпіонат світу з легкої атлетики,
і відразу для Німеччини з'явився шанс
на отримання медалі
за спортивну ходьбу понад 20 км.
Крістофер Лінке з міста Потсдам
зайняв 4 місце
у попередньому Чемпіонаті світу в Досі.
Його перспективні змагання
починаються незабаром після опівночі.
Чемпіонат світу в Юджині, штат Орегон,
сьогодні прощається з талановитою спортсменкою
Еллісон Фелікс, 36 років, 7-разовою
золотою призеркою Олімпійських ігор та
13-разовою чемпіонкою світу.
Останній забіг за медалями -
змішана естафета 4х400 м.
Для мене це коло тут, вдома, зараз завершальне.
І це справді, дуже особливий момент.
Трістан Швидке, перший гравець команди DLV,
вже вибув у кваліфікації з метання молота.
І про нього також розкажемо за годину
у прямому ефірі на сайті «sportstudio.de.».
Коротко про погоду: на вихідних переважно тепло,
на півночі - хмари та невеликий дощ.
Детальніше згодом розповість Катя Горнеффер.
Нагадуємо про перегляд «heute journal» з
Беттіною Шаустен сьогодні о 22:00.
Не пропустіть, також, завтрашній ефір
з Барбарою Галвег.
Дякуємо, що були з нами та
гарного початку вихідних!
Бережіть себе.
Добрий вечір.
Можливо, Ви сьогодні також зраділи
дощу, який пролився у Північній Німеччині.
Прийшов час для іншого циклону, який
також приносить дощ.
У першій половині ночі прогнозують дощ
на узбережжі Північного моря.
У другій половині ночі
дощ рухатиметься далі на схід.
Місцями можливі короткочасні грози.
На південь від Північного низького хребта - сухо.
Температура опуститься до 14°
у Люнебурзькій пустелі
та на Нижньому Рейні і до
6° тут, у Верхньому Пфальці.
Найвищі температури термометра
завтра на морі - від 17° до 20°.
У Баварії позначка термометра показуватиме 20-24°.
У Баден-Вюртемберзі, частинах Гессену
та на федеративних землях
Рейнланд-Пфальц та Саарланд - від 25° до 29° градусів.
Завтра вранці тут на сході можуть бути останні зливи
і грози, які потім швидко рухатимуться на схід
з досить сильним
вітром з північно-західного напрямку.
Місцями більше, місцями менше хмар,
але найсонячніша погода — між
хребтом Карвендель та Верхнім Рейном.
У неділю на Півдні Німеччини буде ще більше сонця
з температурою від 26° до 32°.
На півночі - хмарно, але недовго, потім приходить
спека аж до 41°, орієнтовно з вівторка.
До зустрічі.